all right um
thank you again
for all of you who have joined today's
session and wanted to learn about
uh km informatics in biomedical drug
discovery so for today's session we did
we discussed and we thought that we will
be it will be nice
to discuss some of the critical
opportunities and challenges that are
being faced by the industry faced by
research labs and uh we wanted to
discuss about the overview of how this
entire modern drug discovery pipeline is
now functioning
and it's producing results in many
places and many of you are excited for
the same reasons to be able to
explore more of this and to be able to
learn and apply to some of your own
research
so um as we go on for the session as we
discuss different uh different uh
different agendas for today's meeting
i'd like to request sonalika to maybe
prepare a project proposal form
and uh share it with me uh sonalika if
you can do that uh so towards the end of
the session i will want to discuss the
project proposal and how one can start
working on a research idea already uh
starting with the uh
as the program starts
in uh fixed time so uh
uh as uh we've been discussing that
there are certain agendas that we would
want to cover one of those agendas is
precision medicine so when we are
discussing about biomedical drug
discovery when we are discussing about
the use of chem informatics in
biomedical drug discovery we are talking
about a specific specialization that
involves structural biology that
involves understanding of how uh to
analyze three-dimensional
structures in three-dimensional space
and how to uh you know device strategies
as well so uh i mean to think about that
there are other two other two aspects
that uh we would be discussing those are
drug designing and drug repurposing um
which are
used quite often in even in industry as
well as in academia
and during the presentation and during
the session i'll be happy to answer
questions so please put there put your
questions in the chat
so in this training program
uh
what we have discussed about what we
have discussed so far is about the
different aspects of
biomedical drug discovery but in the
training program we are going to follow
a curriculum and that curriculum would
include specific
softwares and tools which are open
source and we will be able to share with
you how to install those softwares and
how to use them on the cloud and uh what
are the
uh what are the associated resources
that you can utilize to make the most
out of this uh training program that is
upcoming so we have planned a very
detailed curriculum that i'll be
showcasing and i'll be going through
but before that i wanted to start with
the fact that what we are doing and why
we are doing this and why we should uh
learn about all of this
so let's start with the fact that
how the modern biomedical drug discovery
pipeline
works and what are the different
components and how can this be an entire
story like a complete story with all the
where we know all the pieces because
what is ha what has happened and what we
know for sure is that
for many drugs that we've been using so
frequently
we don't know the mechanism of action so
having a complete knowledge of mechanism
of action
is is something that the modern
biomedical drug discovery
is utilizing uh
by that is being utilized by former
computational biology or bioinformatics
company that are providing services as
well as
uh
research labs and researchers so how do
we incorporate that
all sort of information into the model
so that it makes sense so that it
relates really close to what is
happening biologically or what is
happening in uh real life situation so
uh i mean in modern biomedical drug
discovery pipeline uh there are certain
aspects that we
that we have covered uh in our omics
logic portal and to those participants
who will be joining this program
obviously connecting those dots and then
uh figuring out uh
maybe targeted protein or a proposal
would make total sense
so um
uh as we were discussing precision
medicine so precision medicine
initiate uh initiating from
uh clinical and molecular pharmacology
introduces a new era in healthcare right
that if the the entire purpose of this
is that it aims to identify and predict
the optimum treatment for a patient or a
cohort
now
uh evidence-based medicine uh integrates
information from basic in vivo
observational studies and then clinical
trials uh
where we're done to do meta-analysis
data for clinical considerations so
hence it it can be stated that this this
entire like often we see that population
averages uh but uh population averages
the forest
but misses the tree so the trees are
here individual patients right where the
utilization of precision medicine may
not see the uh may not see the forest
but for the trees and that is quite uh
relevant and important that we have
realized that all of us are
having a different genetic makeup uh
which makes us different from each other
we react to different medicines
differently so all that information uh
can be you know modeled together so that
we can reach to a place where we can
give recommendations based on the
personalized way of
[Music]
reporting so now the state of our tools
for modeling and simulations and
pharmacology they try to extrapolate
knowledge gain gain through this
experimental process or procedures with
either either a top-down approach or a
bottom-up bottom-up approach so this
modeling and simulation often it what it
does is that it tries to connect the
dots and reveals the bigger picture so
picture the bigger picture is the
population or the forest so considering
what kind of individuals or trees are in
there we have to understand and we have
to figure out at an atomic level and
which is very fascinating and really uh
really uh
nice to know that from uh sequence level
we are looking at the functional level
and then we are looking at the
mechanistic level by looking at the
chemistry that is going on
in the within the molecules so uh in
this program there are some components
that is really exciting for me and i
guess it would be exciting for all of
you as well so um we would want to
discuss this that how research allows
us to utilize experimental or clinical
data through this molecule
modeling and simulation simulation of
biomedical tools and this will help and
this is helping for sure in disease
progression dynamics in machine machine
learning and relevant bioengineering
approaches for either drug response
prediction where like including drug
interactions
drug interaction data is also included
then adverse drug reactions data is also
included and that all of this is leading
to drug repurposing or you know drug
discovery
now uh we also want to understand that
what are like what different this this
slide itself it has a huge number of
information but at the same time it also
tell us about the pathway like what
cellular omics can give us what
microbiome and virum
information can give us and what
clinical and phenotypic data can give us
and when we combine all of this what is
the system biology approach and how then
we
how we can then discuss about the
strategy the strategy is to find a
solution and the solution comes from
chemistry so how do we use those drugs
those may be biologics or based on the
data that we are getting so this various
types of omics data that is described in
detail
intercellular and intracellular
processes which are really associated
with common diseases and these data sets
can be analyzed to understand biology
behind host factors and as well as like
a micro biome composition in our bodies
and the environment we live in so
to drive infections and to cause you
know deterioration of health these also
have an effect on destabilizing the
immune system and let's these all of
this let led to you know clinical
manifestation of a disease
so um
it would be nice to to understand this
from a perspective of you know an
example for of so let's try out an
example
so the way uh in which bacteria infects
infect
cells are important for understanding
the post-pathogen interaction
agreed
so if it is true then the knowledge also
opens up a world of practical
applications so what are the
applications
so for example it can support the design
of
new
anti-antibiotics or vaccines in
in case of
when we are discussing about healthcare
these are the different applications
when we are discussing about the soil or
marine bacteria it can help in creating
strategies for rebalancing natural
ecosystems so there is a huge
application
so one can use machine learning to
explore how bacteria interacts with the
environment by analyzing those so there
is this case study and this is a
recently published
article
in nature
that shows that analyzing data from
uniprot database in itself and using uh
the
protein prediction software that
recently came out alpha fold uh
one can bridge uh like fill this gap and
knowledge in this area so there is this
study where fibrillar edison's these are
the proteins that are located on
bacterial cell surface and which mediate
interactions with the environment for
example host cells or the bacteria or
the other bacteria so there was a study
on this so these proteins are usually
have a stock
which helps them cross the bacterial
cell surface and be projected closer to
their targets so regardless of what they
are trying to bind to they will be they
will be this is the mechanism through
which they work so uh
the study uh analyzed the data from a
couple of species and then uh the
researchers were able to identify
more than 6 500 of such
fibrillar edisons
that were not seen before and this was
done through the sequence analysis so
uniprot is a sequence database
and uh i think many of you know about
uniprop very well and then you uh we
will be discussing in this session also
alpha fold and deep minds uh this
innovation which helped in predicting
the uh structure of those fibrillar
edisons and then we got to know about
from this analysis
a new world perhaps
that is helping in the process of
binding which is so essential for
bacteria so this this work actually goes
beyond simple curiosity because by
understanding how bacteria interacts
with biotin or biotin surfaces
researchers can start to explore how
drug can be used to target these
interactions or whether the bacteria
living in our body or our environment
can be changed so this approach can uh
could allow researchers to improve the
health of gut microbiomes the bacterial
community living in a patient's gut for
example so these are some of the uh
approaches that have been taken up by
the new multi
way of seeing things and then
integrating it with
the system biology approach and then the
computational uh
solutions so in this program and we've
been discussing this
that uh how the different elements are
you know put together so
so when we are discussing about finding
new targets and when we are discussing
about
the data analysis part of
bioinformatics so you have heard about
transcriptomics and like how gene
expression patterns
in association with clinical data
help identify molecular biomarkers which
are used for diagnostics and for therapy
selection so new discoveries include a
better understanding of these complex
diseases at the subcellular level as
well as for target identification uh for
noble drug discovery and even for drug
repurposing so all of this is helpful
for us to
towards
target discovery which is a very
important step in biomedical drug
discovery
now uh new target discovery so target
based screens as many of you are from
but maybe biological background and know
about the target base based screens
so in wet lab or in when we are doing
experiments so target based screens
offer a reductionist approach to drug
discovery because generally it's
employed
in in vitro biochemical assets to search
through the libraries of small molecules
so they are based on developing acids to
detect compounds that interact with the
specific molecular entity most often a
protein right which is known or
hypothesized from a basic research to be
involved in processes impaired in
disease of interest that's the drug
discovery concept that many of us think
it to be
so in that process phenotypic screening
in contrast employs a holistic approach
most often at the level of the cell
sometimes you get that data also from
cell from tissue or from organ or even
whole animals can be employed in some of
those studies so one of such example is
that the personalized medicine example
is uh trust to zubin uh trusts uh travis
to zoom up trastozumab which was a first
in class immunotherapeutic target uh
targeting the her2 dyrasine uh kinase
receptor and it's used to treat patients
with how to over express breast
tumors and we have a project on those
which uh project on this on learn portal
and also we cover it in a
transcriptomics program and but it is
important that how all of this is
connected so there is a molecular
approach that uses
all of these technologies i was
discussing about and gave example for
gene expression studies
where we discussed about a biomarker and
then the
the over expressing
her to
breast tumors and then there are genetic
studies or genomic studies where we are
looking at the panels where we are
looking at the mutations the variants so
these are some approaches then there is
a system approach that i've discussed
then we have all the different uh
validations that we can do utilizing
bioinformatics so this was a kind of an
overview
to what we are doing why we are doing
this and how all of this is connected
because on the portal you will be able
to find uh different omics technologies
and then why we are doing chem
information so this is one of the major
component of this entire drug discovery
process so i hope that all of this
overview is kind of uh makes sense and
it's clear to uh to you
uh if if you have any questions i'll be
happy to um happy to answer so um next
uh part of this program of this
presentation will include that what we
are going to do in terms of the
curriculum how we are going to cover
different aspects of what we have been
discussing and how all of this makes
sense uh if you think about a research
proposal or a research project that you
might be thinking about or you are
interested in the future to work on
so today
we are meeting here and we are
discussing about
the upcoming fall program
which is scheme informatics for
biomedical drug discovery so this uh
program is going to start on 23rd august
and will run till uh october
and
there are uh
models where you can join and complete
the program in either 45 days or 60 days
or 90 days based on the
maybe you are interested to work further
with us or work on a research proposal
all of this is possible within a larger
time frame and uh
in this program we will be covering uh
through sessions and uh there will be
resources so i in this slide i wanted to
uh
simplify to all of uh all of you who are
who are
here today that
how this is
conceptualized and how the curriculum
works and what are the different
components that one will be having
access to to able to be able to get some
of the outcomes that we've been
discussing uh for this so we've been
discussing about the different types of
data different types of approaches and
how structural biology approach is an
important uh
critical component of this but uh you
have like all the coursework associated
with the other omics technologies that
would be integrated into this process
but if you want to work on structure
biology became informatics and you
already have a defined idea or a
research target or sorry
or a target in your mind then i think we
you can start from the
from the
uh
from the coursework that we are going to
offer as a part of this program which is
uh structural biology and chemin from
windex coursework which kind of is
developed for beginners and this is
especially to those uh who are either
from high school or from undergraduate
level and would want to start with a
very basic understanding so all of this
omixlogic training involves a basic
coursework then an intermediate
coursework and then the research work so
for those who wants to get like an
understanding of uh how the basics work
we will be sharing the
resources with you these are the courses
uh lessons that uh will be support that
will be provided uh with every session
uh throughout the training program uh so
that uh everyone who is from a different
educational background or are from
non-biology background could also uh
work on this
so uh as i was saying that from uh
very basics to understanding of why we
are doing this where we can find
information and what kind of data is
there uh so
these all questions are also being and
being answered so uh how protein acts
what is the future of structural biology
how animal spectroscopy works what is uh
what is uh cryo em and what are the
difference between like the when you
when you compare structures when you're
thinking about you know conducting a
experiment
and in silico experiment on structural
biology drug discovery drug designing
what are the things that you need to see
so there are some of the very basic
important facts when you are obtaining
data when you are obtaining structural
data what are the parameters
you can you know uh check to understand
if the model that you're considering is
is of
is going to give you the right answers
or not so those basic concepts are being
uh discussed in these lessons and we are
adding more lessons in this uh in this
series as well which will be which we
will be sharing with the participants of
the program throughout the training